[Music]
thank you
and a very warm welcome to this uh
extremely
pertinent debate wherever you are uh
we're delighted that you've joined us
to talk about inequality something that
afflicts i think
every country in the world and i think
most of us
politicians and commentators included
would
say that they were in favor of reducing
levels of inequality
yet this sentiment doesn't seem to have
much impact on the reality
which amongst other signs is that the
average person
in the 10 richest countries of the world
spends in a single week
more than those in the poorest 10
earn in a year and even in rapidly
growing economies like india greater
prosperity has gone
hand in hand with increasing inequality
so should we conclude that we don't in
fact believe in reducing inequality but
we simply want to be attached to the
moral intent
without any serious plan to deliver it
is there an economic solution that can
enable greater prosperity but also
reduce inequality
or must we redouble our efforts to
rectify the situation and would that
require
accepting radical changes in our
lifestyles
well we have a brilliant panel to tackle
these difficult questions and
i'm delighted to uh introduce the nobel
prize-winning an econo
economist public intellectual uh
professor joseph stiglitz
he is a former senior vice president and
chief economist of the world bank and is
currently
a professor at columbia university i'm
also joined by grace blakely who's an
economics commentator a former
researcher at the institute for public
policy research and the author of corona
crash
how the pandemic will change capitalism
and lisa nandy lisa has held a number of
shadow cabinet posts and is now
the shadow foreign secretary welcome to
all of you
and i'm going to start by asking each of
you
to i guess tackle this this conundrum
which i i've referred to which is that
although
we claim to believe in reducing global
inequality our kind of lack of effect
might suggest we don't mean it and
perhaps we should admit that we don't
really believe it um so grace kick us
off
sure um well for me the main point that
i want to be the takeaway from this talk
is that inequality is about power and
because it's about power it's also about
class um and i think that's basically
what's missing from the discussion that
we have about about
uh inequality in the mainstream because
the on narratives are around inequality
whether you're talking about that at the
domestic level
or internationally and it's interesting
the way in which those conversations are
often divorced from one another i'll
come back to that in a minute also
but the narratives we used to talk about
inequality are individualized and that's
because the discipline of economics is
founded upon
assumptions about individuals so
individuals are kind of you know
rational utility maximizing agents
bumping up against one another
in free markets and inequality arises
as a kind of natural um dispersion
of uh rewards for people who you know
work some work harder than others some
are better than others you know
um and some just simply are able to
access certain resources because
they are born into the right place at
the right time etc it's all about
the privileges um or lack of privileges
that are conferred on individuals now
economics is not a discipline today
especially kind of in the mainstream in
neoclassical economics it's not a
discipline that tends to talk much about
class
but coming at this from a a kind of
critical
perspective allows you to understand
obviously you know capitalism as an
economic system is a system that divides
uh people into basically two groups
either you own
capital either you own the stuff that is
needed to produce things or you are
forced to sell your wage
uh for um a living and that obviously
gives us one measure measure of
inequality which is the uh labor share
of national income versus the profit
share of national income
what we've seen in uh economies uh
really kind of
you know particularly in advanced
economies but in many economies around
the world
is that in especially over the last 40
years the profit share has increased
but you also get inequality within the
labor share because
of the way in which um you kind of get a
level especially under kind of
modern um uh globalized and
financialized capitalism you get
um a uh an increasing dispersion within
the wage share that's to do with rewards
for different
roles that are undertaken within the
production process now i'll come back to
this a bit later
but effectively if you are analyzing
global inequality using this class lens
what you're quickly able to see is that
the global
working class is effectively offshored
to the global south that is where the
vast majority of production takes place
and a lot of the better paid jobs in the
rich world are effectively to do with
managing
global production to do with speculating
over value that's created elsewhere
to do with managing uh value change that
to do with you know managing personnel
and that is you know a significant
reason for uh that
you know internal dispersion in incomes
within
uh the wage share um so yeah i mean i
think coming at this from
the perspective of class and from the
perspective of class power
allows you to see some of those things
that you maybe miss when you look at
things from a more individualized
perspective
and i think that is why because you know
often our discussion about inequality
whether you're talking about
domestic or global inequality we compare
and thomas piketty obviously did this in
his book capital the kind of neoliberal
era so the period between the 1980s and
um you know broadly the financial crisis
and the period that preceded that so the
post-war consensus that gloria's
whatever you want to call them
uh which is a period where particularly
in the rich world you saw kind of
falling inequality
um you saw uh you know a fairly more
stable economic system which had a much
greater role for state intervention
and when we talk about this often
especially um you know when we're
thinking about ways to solve inequality
we look back and we think well the
reason for that was obviously we had
keynesian economic policy we had
the bretton woods institutions that um
you know
constrained the power of finance capital
that um
you know constrained the size of finance
excess domestically and therefore
limited
the amount of kind of extraction um that
could take place by those mechanisms
um um you know we talk about all these
keynesian policies and think oh well if
we brought those back then things would
be better
but i think that misses a step which is
that why did we get those keynesian
policies to begin
with well it was because there was a
redistribution of power between capital
and labour that took place in the
aftermath of the second world war
which obviously occurred for a number of
reasons you get much much more important
role for unions during the second world
war because of the
needs of production in the war economy
uh and you get a
state that's much bigger and that
requires much greater taxation on
wealthy individuals to be able to pay
for that war effort
which again helps to shift that that
balance of power
so i think the lesson from that i think
we we're gonna come back to a number of
those themes and
and i'm i i'd like to you know get get
round in our first round so
i'm going to stop you there if that's
all right of course yeah
and ask lisa the same question which is
this
conundrum that we say we're in favor of
inequality inequality persists shouldn't
we admit
that we don't really believe in reducing
it um
well the short answer to that as you
would expect is no i don't think that we
should
and the reason for that is because
inequality isn't just bad for
to borrow a phrase those who are less
equal than others
it's bad for everybody both at a
national level and a global level
the excessive concentration of power as
grace said
of wealth of opportunity is
unjustifiable but it's also
destructive because more equal societies
are stronger they're kinder they're
healthier
and a more equal world is a world that
is more hopeful and more secure
both within countries and across the
world inequality is a problem for all of
us
and we can and should try to address it
however difficult that is
but i think to change this we need to
think differently about the causes
of inequality sometimes i think we
target the wrong people
in the debate for example fast fashion
is rightly condemned for exploitation
and wastefulness
and our response is often ethical
consumerism which is fine as far as it
goes but
the blame for the excesses of the fast
fashion industry don't lie with people
in britain whose incomes have fallen in
recent years
who turn to primark in order to clothe
their children
we won't solve this problem by pitting
working people in bangladesh against
working people in bolton
solidarity is part of the answer not
part of the problem
and the problem is a system that allows
some people to benefit
disproportionately
from an industry that is built on a
model that pushes down costs that
suppresses labor rights and that abuses
human rights
so we need to focus on the drivers of
the system and the structures that
sustain it from how
and what we tax as joseph has written
about to how we regulate finance and the
rights that workers
have as well behind this i think is a
model of
of global trade and finance which
creates imbalances in the world economy
which have profound consequences for
us all countries will cut consumption
and they'll tax working people more for
example or they'll cut social security
payments in order to pay for investment
which facilitates growth now the best
example of that model in recent times i
think is china
um which has harmed those workers in
china
who cannot now afford to consume the
things that they produce
but what it also does is it builds these
big surpluses
that have to find a market elsewhere in
the world and by flooding other markets
with cheap goods other workers in other
countries are disadvantaged
too we've seen this with workers in the
rust belt in america
it creates rising tensions between
countries and it fuels populism
too it is bad for all of us so my view
is that we need a global system that
works in the interests of working people
that promotes trade unions labor rights
living standards and raises
transparency in global supply chains but
my view is also that this starts
at home where our major challenge is to
decouple
growth from rising inequality and carbon
consumption the two
twin challenges for our economy we need
an industrial policy that invests in
green economies we need real action on
pay
and that by the way means overcoming
this divide in value
and status between high and low skilled
jobs how can it possibly be
for example the middle of a global
pandemic
that care workers are deemed low skilled
by their own government in this country
we've got to invest in the education and
skills of workers and expect companies
to do so too
there is a reason that the car industry
in the northeast of england is likely to
survive brexit
despite all the damage that even a no
deal brexit can do and that is because
the skills
of the workforce are worth paying for
but until we measure
and value the right things my view is
this is not going to change we obsess
about gdp
growth rather than about how that growth
is distributed
or the quality of life that it leads to
we measure everything in short
except that which makes life worthwhile
but as we've learned through this global
pandemic
with all of the upheaval that it's
brought to people's daily lives if you
change the lens through which you see
the world
suddenly the things that matter come
back into focus again
that's the sentiment that i think we
need to rediscover in this debate as we
start to think seriously
about how we build back better thanks
lisa and joseph let me go straight on to
you to this question about
this gap between what we say we want and
and actually what
what we don't do shouldn't we just admit
there's a gap there
and recognize it oh there is a gap
obviously and i'm going to take your
question at face value
uh obviously uh people always care more
about their family than their community
about their community
rather than the broader society and
our nation and then uh that more than
they do
about the world uh
that that's sort of natural so there
there's
uh no uh commitment to
complete equality that's that's
obviously very
clear but i think uh especially in
britain you should be uh
proud of the fact that one of the things
that
governments in both parties have done
as the base and budget constraints
you did do some protecting over the
overseas development budget
of the oda budget and so you did
more than a lot of other countries in
the uk
you did make a commitment not fully
realized that a lot of it going to to
uh uh you know uh iraq afghanistan
uh very special circumstances you did
make
some commitment more than others to
redistribution across boundaries but
there are two other points that i think
have already been raised that i just
want to
highlight um the first is
this is not a zero sum and that
it is in our self-interest to have some
redistribution
that uh the global economy is weaker
when there's more inequality just like
the national economy
is weaker you know that that was
reflected in the book that i
wrote called the price of inequality we
pay a high price of inequality within
our
boundaries nationally and we do that
globally and secondly um
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas